these balls represent one of the
strangest phenomena currently taking
place in our universe each ball
symbolizes one of the 100,000 galaxies
including our own that are currently
being pulled towards a mysterious point
in our universe called the Great
Attractor we can't see exactly what it's
pulling us there but the only force that
would be capable of doing so is gravity
so whatever is out there it's massive
and unrelenting how far away is the
Great Attractor what happens when our
galaxy gets pulled into it and will we
ever be able to see the source of its
power this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Great Attractor
swallowed our galaxy going back to our
ball example you can see that if you
have 100 thousand galaxies all moving
towards the same destination the odds
are that some if not most of them are
going to collide with each other and if
you've been watching our videos you
probably know that almost every one of
those galaxies would have a black hole
at its center so what can we expect to
happen when nearly 100,000 black holes
merge with one another before we get
ahead of ourselves let's get to know
these 100,000 galaxies a little better
our galaxy the Milky Way belongs to a
group of a few dozen galaxies called the
local group cool just like the Sun's
gravity pulls the earth toward in our
galaxy is pulled towards the other
galaxies in our local group
our local group belongs to an even
bigger collection of galaxies called the
Virgo supercluster and this super
cluster belongs to an even larger super
cluster known as Laniakea the one thing
all these clusters have in common is
that they're all being pulled towards
one specific spot 220 million light
years away known as the Great Attractor
[Music]
it's vast distance away coupled with all
the gas and dust that surrounds it has
made it virtually invisible ever since
its discovery until now thanks to x-ray
and radio astronomers we can now see
behind this cloud of gas and dust so now
we know that this great attractor is
really just another super cluster named
the norma super cluster norma has the
mass of about 1,000 trillion Suns which
might explain why it's so attractive to
these 100,000 galaxies so now we know
where our galaxy is heading and why
we're heading there but what could
happen along the way well for one thing
we could collide with another one of the
100,000 galaxies heading that way
the most likely one being our closest
neighbor Andromeda if these two spiral
galaxies collided they would merge into
one new elliptical galaxy during the
collision vast clouds of hydrogen would
become compressed and rapidly create new
stars this would result in the premature
aging of the new galaxies as it used up
its fuel that doesn't seem too bad but
that's because the black holes in the
center of these galaxies haven't
collided yet
when these two black holes merge it will
release energy equivalent to three times
the mass of our Sun within a matter of
seconds that would be enough power to
create a disturbance in the space-time
continuum and that's just two black
holes colliding if all the black holes
of the 100,000 galaxies drifting towards
the Great Attractor merged together it
would release more energy than we could
ever imagine
but luckily we won't have to worry about
that because these galaxies will
probably never arrive at the same spot
and collide you see the Great Attractor
is also being pulled deeper into space
by other massive clusters and these
100,000 galaxies are also constantly
drifting apart further away from each
other the universe is constantly
expanding and that expansion will be
stronger than even the great attractors
pull what will eventually happen is that
Laniakea itself will come apart and all
the galaxies within this super cluster
will start to drift even further apart
so there's no big collision no humanity
destroying event to end this episode
just a bunch of galaxies drifting off
into the abyss will they ever stop well
that's a story for another what-if
[Music]
you